mais d'abord donc c'est un zoom sur le
programme économique de la nu ps que je
vous propose tout de suite avec mathias
arese
certains parlent de 332 milliards
d'autres de plus de 250 difficile de
savoir qui dit vrai lorsqu'on évoque le
programme économique de la nuque attaqué
de toutes parts sur la faisabilité du
projet jean luc mélenchon a contre
attaqué ce mardi
mon prédécesseur et la droite l'extrême
droite et le gouvernement
joue la carte de la peur de l'affolement
un l'hiver nucléaire les sauterelles et
la catastrophe économique dans une
tradition qui avait été abandonné depuis
la période de monsieur giscard d'estaing
qui annonce et les mêmes valeurs au pays
c'est monsieur françois mitterrand était
élu et je souhaite à nos critiques le
même destin pour donner du poids à son
propos le troisième homme de la
présidentielle qui s'est souvent vantée
d'être soutenus par plus d'une centaine
d'économistes a donné la parole à
certains d'entre eux en tête de gondole
les économistes atterrés cédric durand
et eric baer ce que le programme proposé
par la nuque et un programme sérieux
d'un programme financé il a certes un
effet multiplicateur mais aussi une base
fiscale qui est tout à fait solidaire et
au delà de ça il ya un projet productif
industrielle de planification qui vise à
consolider la base productive du pays et
donc sa base fiscale seul point noir au
tableau l'événement organisé à la hâte
ce n'était question pieds elle est fille
les poids lourds écologistes socialistes
et communistes n'étaient pas là on en
débat tout de suite avec mes invités
béatrice giblin bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes géographe directrice de la revue
hérodote j'accueille également pierre
jacqmin plus à l'acte en chef de la
revue regards avec à la une jean luc
mélenchon la gauche c'est lui jean
daniel lévy directeur délégué de harris
interactive bonsoir excellente elle est
ici aqlpa éditrice poétique bon soir
bienvenue à vous merci d'être là comme
chaque mardi et chaque jeudi dans ce
sens public le programme économique dont
pour pour commencer béatrice giblin est
ce que vous vous le jugez crédible
réaliste ça dépend combien de temps ils
veulent réaliser s'il met tout sur la
table comme ça rapidement que ce soit la
retraite à 60 ans que ce soit le smic à
1500 que ce soit
l'autonomie
l'allocation d'autonomie pour les jeunes
depuis 18 ans que bon et cetera et
cetera l'aja veut dire qu'on va faire
sauter la caisse ça me semble évident
maintenant est ce que il imagine on
qu'il soit à la tête du gouvernement
quelles seraient ses priorités
qu'est ce qui mettrait d'abord en valeur
qu'est-ce qui tenait qu il je deale
parce qu'il a quand même un peu tendance
à décider donc il il décide avec ce
qu'il faudrait faire parce que ce qui
quand on entend les économistes atterrés
dire ben voilà ces chiffres s est solide
il n'y a pas de raison on prend jamais
véritablement
les réactions de ceux qui seraient pas
contents en particulier que certains
chefs d'entreprise par exemple puisqu'on
a annoncé qu on taxerait des andes les
entreprises il est possible qu'ils
mettent des de la mauvaise humeur par
exemple qu'ils cessent d'investir ou
qu'ils cessent d'embauché pour les moins
patriote qui peut-être mettre de
l'argent ailleurs bon donc je ressors
pensez y si tu es mitterrand en 1981
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des décisions
prises sur le plan économique y compris
dans la revalorisation du salaire
minimum mais aussi dans des choses tout
à fait important de la régularisation
par exemple des travailleurs étrangers
puis en 83 la situation avec beaucoup de
si prince en grèce qui a essayé de faire
un certain nombre de choses et puis
autour de bâton alors été
je me tourne vers vous pierre jacqmin le
19 mai dernier le cercle de réflexion de
dire de centre gauche terra nova avait
qualifié le programme économique de la
de la nuque ou delà du psg sita
davanture populiste qui mènerait au
désastre et affecteraient durablement le
pouvoir d'achat des français
ça vous a fait réagir je le sais 7 cette
note de terra nova pourquoi d'abord
c'est toujours un intrigant de voir de
quelle manière on interroge toujours la
crédibilité d'un programme de gauche la
crédibilité économique d'un programme de
gauche comme si la gauche n'était pas en
capacité d'avoir une démonstration
d'avoir une proposition économique
différente de celle qu'on a connue par
le passé y compris d'ailleurs sous des
gouvernements de gauche parce qu'on peut
pas dire que le système économique avec
le monde de la finance qui devait être
l'ennemi était un programme économique
véritablement ancré à gauche ou en tout
cas avec des ruptures radicales après il
ya eu ce rapport de terra nova qui
d'ailleurs est intéressant parce que il
aimait les critiques sur lesquels jean
luc mélenchon était lui-même amenés à
répondre il
j'aime cette politique la star ac c'est
une confrontation d'idées de projets un
projet la fondation terra nova vous avez
dit qu'elle était de gauche sans doute
est ce en creux d'une certaine manière
au parti socialiste pour ce qu'il en est
ce qu'il en reste et ce qu'il en reste
de la pensée économique aussi au sein du
parti socialiste
je j'ai noté aussi que dans cette note
il avait fait référence beaucoup à des
chiffres qui avaient été réalisés en
tout cas des études qui avait été
réalisé par l'institut montaigne qui
n'est pas franchement un institut classé
à gauche donc bon chose intéressante
l'idée vous quand vous analysez ce
programme où trouver la liste moi est ce
que je sais que je pense que je moi je
pense en termes politiques faire qu'à un
moment donné quand on fait de la
politique
d'une manière générale d'ailleurs c'est
un peu le clivage droite gauche c'est à
dire soit on pense que l'économie doit
être au service de la politique soit on
pense que la politique de service de
l'économie de ce débat sur la
crédibilité du programme de lannux je
trouve illustre assez bien ce ce débat
là c'est à dire que soit on se fixe des
objectifs soit on fait de la politique
on se fixe par des cap des objectifs et
on trouve les ressources pour financer
ce cap et ses objectifs cette utopie
même parfois soit on prend à l'effet
inverse c'est un peu l'effet que
emmanuel macron et les politiques
libérales de ces dernières années ont
mené c'est à dire on dit voilà l'état
des comptes publics et voilà ce qu on
est en capacité de faire et si on veut
faire autre chose voilà on va réduire
les dépenses publiques et bien laquelle
le débat sur les retraites c'est
exactement ce qui se passe les retraites
il ya une année mâcon qu'il me dit on
n'a plus d'argent il faut mais il faut
augmenter l'âge de départ légal à la
retraite et puis à la gauche qui dit
banon et joue pas mais celle là il faut
pas augmenter l'âge de départ légal à la
retraire parce que c'est un objectif
pour le relire 60 ans et il faut trouver
la recette pour financer les oppose mais
l'enfant est ce que quelqu'un peut
m'expliquer ici je vais faire le rôle de
la citoyenne mail pourquoi la nuque nous
présente un programme économique en fait
je ne comprends pas pourquoi les
présidents se sont déjà passés enfin je
veux dire là on est on va le voter pour
des députés mais les députés vont pas
mettre en place un programme eco c'est
lui qui met en place
continue dans la stratégie de
communication de mélenchon qui est parti
donc sur un fake je serai à matignon ces
salles à l'idée
vous comprenez une visibilité suffisante
c'est exactement ce que je pensais de
parler avant même l'intervention des
petits ça c'est qu'il ya aujourd'hui en
tête la nuque qui arrive à marquer
encore une fois le débat la semaine
c'est à dire que c'est eux qui lisent en
fait on va parler de notre programme
économique on va imposer un thème est
derrière cette question a déposé
aujourd'hui qu'elle a lu puis c'est à
dire qu'à aucun moment le président
l'appliquent d'interroger le
rassemblement national n'est pas
interrogé pas plus que les républicains
alors même qu' ils se sont quand même où
ils vont quand même avoir un rôle à
jouer quelles que soient leurs forces au
sein de hausse à l'assemblée le deuxième
point que je trouve intéressant c'est
que il ya des questions qui se pose de
manière différente en fonction de la
position qu'on peut avoir à l'égard de
la nuque quand vous interrogez
aujourd'hui les électeurs de la nuque
pouvoir même d'une manière globale des
électeurs qui se voyait la gauche la
question la crédibilité n'est pas au
centre de leurs interrogations et ce
pour deux raisons la première raison
c'est qu'à jean critiques majeures à
l'égard de ce cap et de fait d'un point
de vue économique par le gouvernement et
les gouvernements sortants en
considérant que à cet égard ils n'ont
pas atteint les objectifs et que un
stand de mission que s'est assignée
n'ont pas été obtenus depuis le deuxième
aspect c'est que autant en 2007 en 2012
et pour partie en 2017 la question en
fait de la dette et des déficits était
au centre des préoccupations de la part
de nos compatriotes 2012 quand françois
hollande a été élu président
l'appliquent c'était la deuxième
motivation de vote des électeurs là
quand vous regardez on est revenus
vraiment une préoccupation qui sont au
milieu ou en queue de tableau parce
qu'il ya toujours cette petite idée du
quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il en coûte
est toujours présent je suis pas en
train de justifier j'ai décidé de le
mettre en perspective et donc dans ce
contexte là est-ce que ça va creuser la
dette est-ce que ça va creuser les
déficits est ce que c'est finançable est
ce que ça peut avoir des effets à moyen
ou long terme sur l'ensemble de notre
dispositif économique là ça n'est pas la
question et c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle aujourd'hui quand nous on teste
les propositions qui peut être effectué
de la part de la nuque globalement les
différentes propositions qui sont à la
retraite à 60 ans le smic à 1500 euros
le blocage des loyers l'augmentation
enfin le bloque pas le blocage des
loyers le blocage des dépôts des prix
également globalement ça suscite une
adhésion qui est une adhésion
extrêmement forte même de la part de
personnes qui sont pas aujourd'hui prête
ou enclines à voter pour la nuit
laetitia toujours sur cet aspect
économique il ya c'est à cette carte du
name and shame là on va dire la
dénonciation des plus riches qui est
jouée par par les amis de jean-luc
mélenchon oui et elle est même plus que
jouer thomas puisqu'ils ont décidé sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment sur
twitter de publier les photographies de
patrons qui supposément 1 selon leur
démonstration profiterait du système
capitaliste et aurait des émoluments des
émoluments coup totalement
disproportionnée sur réaliste par
exemple alexandre bompard patron de
carrefour donc sa photo est posté
en disant qu'ils gagnent le salaire de
300 fois peut-être le cimic enfin voyez
vous donc il désigne en fait nommément
et puis picturalement j'allais dire les
voilà les les hommes riches qui seraient
les profiteurs du système donc on est
toujours dans cette stratégie de
communication très efficace puisque name
and shame ça veut dire nommé et pouvoir
peut-être blâmer ses voiles et les
patrons qui profitera encore une fois du
système capitaliste et donc c'est très
facile pour les lecteurs de peut-être
s'offusquer et de voter ensuite dimanche
puisque c'est quand même la finalité un
de ces de ces stratégies de voter
dimanche pour mettre un but en contre ce
système qui finalement a juste béatrice
giblin c'est de la bonne politique
ce n'est match m ou trouvé ça un peu
exagéré voire malsain on se trouve pas
ça de la bonne politique quand on
commence à ce genre de choses on sait
pas exactement où ça là où ça s'arrête
donc name and shame c'est ça vient du
milieu anglo saxons c'est vrai c'est pas
blâmer c'est la honte c'est cette honte
à quelqu'un c'est beaucoup plus que le
blâme de mon point de vue mais si on est
sur ces préoccupations là aujourd'hui
c'est parce que les contraintes
européennes ont changé pourquoi françois
hollande qui a pu dire effectivement mon
ennemi c'est la finance et puis a été
contraint
après être allé à berlin
ou à bruxelles de te dire c'est foutu 3%
qu'on n'a jamais respecté non plus pas
plus que les 60 % mais quand même qu'ils
étaient des marqueurs importants et puis
il ya eu la qu'ovide et puis ce qui a
complètement changé et c'est cet emprunt
commun qu on a pu faire c'est à dire
d'une certaine façon ce qui était gravé
dans le marbre ou qu'on considérait
comme tel visiblement ça s'est un peu
effacé bon et que donc à partir de ce
moment là on a pu emprunter les taux
étaient extrêmement bas et donc tout
allait très tout allait très bien ce qui
permet de dire bon ben voilà oui on a de
la dette mais il faut relancer et puis
on tire les enseignements de 2008 où
2008 effectivement l'europe n'a pas
relancé à serrer la vis et on a maintenu
un chômage de masse et un
appauvrissement des des plus faibles
donc on est complètement dans une autre
configuration
ce qui explique les thèmes aujourd'hui
avec l'inflation soit devenu ces thèmes
centraux rien ne dit que avec
l'inflation alors il ya deux points de
vue c'est les prix augmentent donc les
salaires augmentent donc les prix
augmentent donc est mort coualan book et
puis mélenchon dit mais non c'est pas ça
la boucle c'est les superprofits un qui
fait qu effectivement après ça on est
obligées et de répondre un peu aux
salaires c'est le problème des profits
c'est pas le problème de la demande bon
d'accord mais on se trouve en ce moment
si vous voulez avec une pression
possible sur des taux d'intérêt qui
risquent de remonter sans aucun pas moi
je pense probablement avec la nécessité
d'emprunter et avec un programme qu'on
l'ait mots qu'on n'aime pas c'est le jeu
du rapport de force financier il est ce
qu'il est et à partir de ce moment là
dans ce rapport de force financier on
imposera à la france et mélenchon pour
un crier autant qu'il veut la politique
la politique et l'économique doit suivre
ben oui mais le rapport de force fera
qu'il sera obligé de tenir compte d'un
certain nombre de choses je dis pas que
ce soit forcément une bonne chose et
c'est ce qui se passera alors je
voudrais c'est l'une des infos de cette
fin d'après midi et on va en parler pas
trop longtemps que si beaucoup de thèmes
à aborder mais quand même c'est
important le conseil d'état a tranché en
faveur de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et social sur cette requête
vous savez vie de la nuance politique
pour comptabiliser les les voix aux
législatives de de ce 12 et 19 juin donc
le ministre de l'intérieur devra prendre
la du ps ou la nuque comme une nuance
politique à part entière pierre jacqmin
c'est une vraie victoire c'est pas ça va
pas changer la face de l'élection c'est
un peu de la cuisine mais quand même
c'est une victoire vous avez raison
c'est une petite victoire parce que
c'est une victoire symbolique sur
laquelle c'est que qu'a contesté
justement là du ps parce que le
ministère l'intérieur avec l'autorité
qui était celle de gérald darmanin avait
souhaité que la comptabilité et des
résultats aux élections législatives
fasse en sorte qu on ne calcule pas à
l'intégralité de cette nouvelle
coalition cette nouvelle union populaire
mais qu'on fasse un départage entre eux
ce que veulent les résultats du parti
des candidats socialistes des candidats
écologistes et des candidats communistes
et icônes l'air si la nuque n'est pas un
peu comme si la nuque n'existait pas et
que on me faisait comme auparavant et
qu'on ne compte pas la globalité de ce
qu'est cette nouvelle force qui
représentera une nouvelle force à
l'issue du scrutin de dimanche et de
dimanche prochain avec cette volonté
évidemment- emmanuel macron en tout cas
de la majorité sans doute de faire la
démonstration qu'ils seront la première
force politique ensemble cette nouvelle
coalition qui elle pour la peine était
reconnu a pas de problème ans alors
qu'il ya quand même horizon agir en leur
faveur le même blague le modem
exactement il n'y avait pas de problème
mais par contre pour la nouvelle
coalition de gauche a posé un problème
donc la démonstration de force en tout
cas l'entourloupe où la mer la
manipulation politique du conseil qui
consistait à hamon de rire le résultat
de la gauche qui semble être un tout
petit peu conforté par cette stratégie
nouvelle est pas passée inaperçue au
conseil d'état de toute façon le travail
on leur faisait oui l'auriez fait
comptabiliser la loupe quelle que soit
la décision des médecins après sa mort
et faciliter la tâche d'avoir depuis une
semaine un peu plus classification parce
qu'en fait il a tout du classé à la main
alors après bon c'est un fait maintenant
ce qui est pas certain c'est l'effet
politique que ça pourra produire
dimanche soir on verra ce que ça donne
mais si jamais en fait on a une
projection c'est un score déjà
d'intenses débats de vote au premier
tour important pour la nuque et si on a
une projection en sièges alors avec
laquelle il faudra être extrêmement
prudent mais qui montre une dynamique
véritable pour la nuque ça peut même
avoir un effet de mobilisation de
l'autre camp politique parce qu'on sait
qu'il ya un côté repoussoir de jean-luc
mélenchon et ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il ya un côté plus repoussoir
d'ailleurs de la personnalité jean luc
mélenchon que les programmes politiques
et qui est proposé est que quand vous
regardez un peu ce que peuvent être les
différents chiffres rouges notamment à
l'égard des lecteurs qui vont situé au
centre gauche jusqu'à une partie de la
droite l'idée d'avoir jean luc mélenchon
premier ministre demande ça leur suscite
une vraie interrogation voire même une
angoisse pierre germain fc référence à
1981 à cet égard on n'est pas très loin
de ça en fait au port à se dire que les
chars russes vous présenter à l'arrimer
et qui pourrait donc sur les premiers
résultats qu'on a eus sur les france et
l'étranger kim a une population de
sociologie très favorable à la gauche et
encore moins celle de jean luc mélenchon
la stratégie des candidats des français
l'étranger s'étaient imposés à côté de
jean luc mélenchon donc on peut aussi
estimer et se dire que finalement la
figure de jean luc mélenchon n'est pas
si repoussoir que ça le vote des
français de l'étranger je n'avais pas
prévu de le mettre à ce moment là dans
le débat mais puisque vous en parlez on
y va je propose
là jonathan
de me rejoindre
bonsoir bienvenue
comment quels enseignements on peut
tirer de ce vote des français de
l'étranger mais déjà le premier
enseignement qu'on peut sans doute tiré
thomass c'est que les macro ni stellan
ups sont à couteaux tirés la majorité
présidentielle est arrivée en tête dans
huit des 11 circonscriptions de
l'étranger
mais dans plusieurs endroits la
coalition de gauche elle vraiment elle
talonne le renaissance et pourtant même
dans des circonscriptions qui était
acquise en marche illustration vous
allez le voir sur ces images dans la
circonscription nord américaine roland
lescure qui est le président sortant de
la commission des affaires économiques
de l'assemblée nationale c'est un pilier
de la macro ni et bien lui en fait il
est passé en tête à 35 % des voix mais
il recueille 22 points de moins qu'en
2017 est juste derrière lui en embuscade
et bien il ya la candidate france
insoumise nubes florence roger qui est à
33,43 % des voix il ya aussi une autre
circonscription assez serré c'est la
neuvième celle qui recouvre le maghreb
et l'afrique de l'ouest dans cette
circonscription de ces l'ancienne
ministre elisabeth moreno qui s'est
qualifié pour le second tour avec 28%
des suffrages mais elle est en
ballottage défavorable
derrière le candidat du ps karim benzema
qui est arrivée largement devant avec
près de 40% des suffrages et puis y'a
même évidemment c'est un accident
industriel dont on a beaucoup parlé côté
macro 10 mais cet accident industriel il
s'appelle manuel valls l'ancien premier
ministre lui lorgner sur la 5e
circonscription des français de
l'étranger
recouvrant l'espagne le portugal andorre
monaco et lui il avait été
officiellement investi par en marche
mais face au sortant qui lui étaient
entrés en dissidence avait provoqué sa
sa colère lui s'appelle stéphane auge
états et donc non la fin de l'histoire
on la connaît manuel valls a été
sèchement désavoué dès le premier tour
avec 15% des voix voilà en tout cas ce
qu en a dit le ministre la fonction
publique stanislas guérini moi j'étais
déçu pour lui j'étais déçu pour nous
parce que je suis cohérent c'était le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
je veux vraiment saluer son courage
politique sa volonté de servir à tout
prix le pays il exprime comme ça c'est
dans ses tripes c'est dans son sens
et je crois que ça a beaucoup de valeur
d'aller à l'élection et dans ceux qui
souhaitent ne pas le faire on en a
quelques exemples mêmes qui veulent être
élus produit né soyez et puis à ceux qui
vont se confronter aux électeurs voilà
et manuel valls a pris acte de son score
et qui n'a pas convaincu les électeurs
dit il il s'est contenté d'un laconique
adieu twitter pour nous dire au revoir à
pour quitter le réseau social c'est ça
merci beaucoup avait une petite chute
peut-être est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut
pour autant déduire un grand
enseignement par rapport aux scrutins
qui qui va se produire dans une semaine
d'un peut-être pas en tout cas ce n'est
peut-être pas la répétition générale
conques on pourrait y voir les français
de l'étranger il faut savoir quand même
c'est un scrutin aussi très particulière
dans une part aussi se fait par internet
et il ya aussi un taux de participation
extrêmement faible avec ce week-end y
avait 22 % de votants effectivement
c'est très très faible évidemment la
première leçon c'est cette claque reçue
par manuel valls père jacques maheas
qu'elle était prévisible si l'on en
croit le le député sortant l air eau m
réponse est oui écoutez avec le recul on
aurait pu se dire que a priori emmanuel
manuel valls pardon a fait le travail
depuis longtemps il a rallié emmanuel
macron il a été loyal à emmanuel macron
il a été convaincu par la politique d'
emmanuel macron et il a fait je trouve
ce travail de manière très loyal je
trouve que l'atterrissage d'une sa
conception où il ya un député sortant
qui a priori a fait plutôt du bon
travail ça a été dit et redit il a
beaucoup travaillé sur la question
scolaire à l'étranger
donc cet atterrissage ne me paraît pas
être un signe
d'une réelle volonté d' emmanuel macron
de voir manuel valls siéger à
l'assemblée nationale dans celle à
majorité peut être un piège donc j'ai le
sentiment quand même que oui il ya une
forme d'humiliation chez emmanuel macron
en n'ayant pas franchement soutenu non
j'exagère peut-être mais le terme d'
humiliation la dernière sans doute mais
là pour la peine il a été ma chronique b
a quand même
ce qu'ils on connaît très bien
il se croit toujours être manuel valls
un peu plus puissant et un peu plus fort
regarder barcelone il pense qu'il va
être maire de barcelone est finie
conseiller municipal avec à son bord dix
jours nos positions 15% des voix donc il
a une assez grande confiance en lui on
va dire les choses comme ça et espagnols
voilà ici voyez en négligeant alors
qu'il a été lui militants pendant des
années et des années manuel valls voilà
ça il n'est pas arrivé avec tout de
suite un poste d'élu ça n'a pas été ça
sur argenteuil il ay la ram est quand
même pendant des années bon et là je
pense qu'il a sous-estimé
l'investissement effectivement devosge
état qui était déjà sur la place depuis
à peu près une vingtaine d'années à
travailler à se présenter voilà et qui a
effectivement eu les résultats
qu'on pouvait attendre des ce qu'il a
fait le travail on le verra peut-être ce
au niveau de la métropole avec un
certain nombre de militants qui
pensaient pouvoir de gauche qui
pensaient pouvoir est investi et puis
qui se trouvent balayées pas ce
qu'arrive un hub est qu'ils connaissent
pas bon quand on décide c'est lui et les
gens sont pas contents parce que quand
on a fait tout un travail de militant et
qu'on a bien travaillé est balayée comme
ça c'est douloureux on va dire petit
petit complément d'information par
rapport à la chronique de jonathan il a
quitté twitter parce qu'il a été victime
de ce qu'on appelle pardon du terme une
chic storm c'est à dire que il a eu une
avalanche de messages très insultant et
donc il a préféré quitter le réseau
social
pour peut-être se protéger un message
est effectivement contre manuel valls
journal de lévis est ce que alors je je
parle pas simplement des réseaux sociaux
mais est ce que quand vous étudiez la
figure politique de manuel valls est-ce
qu'il est durablement rejeté par les
français l'organisation concernant sa
sincérité est ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que le moment fait de
rupture concernant son propos sur la
sincérité c'est quand il est entré en
campagne dans la primaire socialiste
parce qu'il a dit qu'il abandonnerait le
49-3 si jamais il devait être élu
président de la réplique est en fait
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec manuel
valls il est toujours apparu comme étant
autoritaire a donné des coups de menton
à avoir eu des propos virulents et à
avoir un affrontement qui était clair et
net on apprécie elle apprécie pas mais
au moins c'était lui à partir du moment
où il a dit qu'il quittait et qu'il a
abandonné cette thématique du 49 3 il ya
eu en fait toute une partie de sa
personnalité ou la sincérité de son
propos qui s'est profondément écroulé et
puis après par la suite quand vous
regardez les différentes prises de
position c'est pas toutes ses prises de
positions mais certaines sont venues
alimenter ce propos étaient engagés à
soutenir le candidat désigné par la
primaire socialiste en l'occurrence et
benoît hamon qu'à gagner il s'est rallié
à emmanuel macron il a indiqué en fait
qu'il quittait la vie politique
française pour aller à barcelone vous
l'avez rappelé et au final après il a
dit en fait que ba sa vie au final était
en france il est présent à nouveau dans
la 5e circonscription sans avoir montré
par la suite par le passé une véritable
inclination à défendre en fait a priori
cette terre-là et quand on regarde là
mais c'est valable également dans
d'autres aspects c'est que il ya une
forme de confort de la sincérité du
propos de la part des électeurs un
candidat cela a été rappelé et qui était
présent depuis une vingtaine d'années
qui était identifiée qui donne le
sentiment d'être vraiment dévoué à son
territoire et dans ce contexte là ça a
permis d'obtenir un score qui était un
score plus important c'est pas le seul
regard qu'on peut porter c'est que quand
vous regardez les autres candidats en
tout cas dans le cas de ces ondes cyr 11
circonscriptions
de france et d'étranger globalement
c'est sensiblement cette même logique
qu'a pu prévaloir même s'il ya une très
forte baisse quand vous regardez 2007
par rapport à 2022 dans chacune des 11
circonscriptions du nombre de voies et
des pourcentages en faveur du candidat
soutenu par la marche il semble et ce
avant même que la sévérité
la réponse politique et graduelle et
proportionnée à la surface de notoriété
parce que j'ai girouette on en connaît
d'autres horreurs berger guillaume
pelletier qui vont d'un parti à un autre
d'un candidat à une autre sans que
finalement le verdict soit aussi
radicale et manuel valls paye aussi sa
place à l'avant scène ça vous fait
réagir oui mais parce que ça a été dit
mais moi j'ai surtout le souvenir de du
du virage de manuel valls en 2015 au
moment de la crise migratoire syrienne
où il va faire ce discours de munich et
il rompt avec la tradition et la
tradition de gauche d'accueil où il dit
la france ne peut plus accueillir
d'étrangers sur son territoires et là il
rompt radicalement avec ce qu'est ce que
la gauche et avec lui le quinquennat qui
s'écoule avec la loi travail et la
déchéance de nationalité donc il ya tout
ça et je disais emmanuel macron
finalement il joue avec un peu avec les
avec les personnalités politiques vous
parlez de roland berger oran verger
c'est aussi une personnalité qu'on
voulait qu'on n'aime pas elle a été
loyal du début à la fin du quinquennat
emmanuel macron peut pas dire qu il les
remercie l a pas eu de ministères à la
jamais été promu on peut pas dire
qu'elle soit très calé étaient
véritablement connus que son travail est
reconnu et manuel valls c'est pareil
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas il a fait
le travail lavandula il a fait la
campagne des maliens de matheron il a
intériorisé cette forme il était
d'accord avec sa réforme sur les
retraites on peut pas dire qu'il ait été
aussi promue par la maladie donc c'est
aussi ça la macro nice est un monde
impitoyable mais mentalement alors c'est
le moment où j'en prenne une autre étape
oui ça
c'est le bateau pour découvrir que
l'affectif et amanda pitoyable excusez
moi mais parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de gens à la france a soumis ce
qu'ont déjà compris que effectivement
c'est et amanda peet responsabilité que
je sache encore pourquoi pas tandis qu'à
l'intérieur du parti simplement un
problème de responsables ça au moins ils
se partagent une chose la macro ni hélas
mélenchonisme ou en tout cas d'un côté
la france sans surprise le côté en
marche c'est qu'est la question de
démocratie à l'intérieur même des
formations politiques on veut pas dire
qu'elle soit représente bon j'allais
dire c'est le moment où j'emploie le mot
prudence dans dans ce débat parce qu'on
va se se plonger dans les dans les
sondages les intentions de vote et
notamment votre dernier baromètre pour
le magazine challenge jean daniel lévy
avec les intentions de vote au premier
tour des élections législatives alors on
commencera prochain c'est dans c'est
dans cinq jours c'est dimanche le
premier tour majorité présidentielle
nous l'a donné à 26% la nu poulain du ps
24% le rassemblement national à 20 % et
le parti est leur état
10 % viennent ensuite les autres que je
ne vais pas forcément cité tout de suite
et alors si on se projette en sièges et
c'est là vous nous avez dit que c'était
il fallait particulièrement prudent je
redis on en arrive à ces honneurs est
quand même là on arrive à cette
fourchette de 280 5 à 3 135 sièges pour
la majorité présidentielle ensemble de
120 184 pour l'un du ps 38 à 58 pour lr
et 30 à 50 pour le rassemblement
national pourquoi vous dites extrême
prudence jean-daniel parce qu'en fait
c'est la projection c'est ce qui va se
passer à l'issue du deuxième tour et
donc là en fait tout plein exercice
alors même qu'on connaît même pas que le
résultat du premier tour alors devoir
vous le faites du matin parce qu'en fait
suppose que si je faisais pas tout de
suite on posa la question de 10 ans
est-ce que d'après vous le l'exécutif
pourra avoir la majorité donc offert ont
dit on va voir et puis en plus il peut y
avoir des décalages très fort en 2017
quand vous regardez je parle même pas
des projections en sièges mais si vous
prenez une circonscription par
circonscription à la main normalement la
majorité présidentielle aurait dû être
beaucoup plus forte à l'issue du
deuxième tour il ya eu un très fort
correctif entre promus tôt au deuxième
tour mais voilà si on se concentre déjà
sur le premier tour que voit-on on voit
une progression globale de la gauche de
la nuque baisse également comme
l'indiquaient des divers gauche ou des
dissidents de gauche on a une petite
baisse des électeurs qui ont l'intention
de voter pour la majorité présentielle
est également de ce qu'on a l'intention
de voter pour une formation politique
telle que par exemple le rassemblement
national ce qui montre bien et c'est un
peu le propos qu'on tient depuis le
début c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a une
formation politique en tout cas un
acteur qui fait campagne autour duquel
tous les débats se focalisent depuis
même pas l'élection présentielle
quasiment même depuis l'autre deux tours
de l'élection présentielle est la force
qui est parvenu à faire jean luc ont un
fond avec ses alliés c'est de faire en
sorte que l'on puisse nous étalonner
l'ensemble de la vie politique autour de
la question du ps vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de la question de la crédibilité
économique mais on a parlé également la
question sociale on peut parler de la
question écologique on peut parler
également de la politique au niveau
international où à chaque fois ça n'est
pas les uns et des autres qui se sont
positionnés mais ça a été un rebond par
rapport à ce que puis d'air à ce qu'il
peut dire à jean luc mélenchon et si
vous prenez ne serait-ce que l'interview
donnez le président applique dans la
presse quotidienne régionale samedi si
jamais jean luc mélenchon la nuque
baisse n'avait pas été aussi fort et
aussi hégémonique en terme de débats
publics qui jamais cette interview voire
même ses propositions à mon avis
n'aurait eu cette tonalité alors
justement vous dites là nue ps et jean
luc mélenchon font l'actualité et donne
en quelque sorte le tempo de cette
campagne présidentielle c'est encore
vrai laetitia avec cet autre polémique
autour de ce tweet concernant la police
jean luc mélenchon qui tweet après la
mort d'une jeune femme dans le contrôle
de police empêchait pas un refus
d'obtempérer vous le savez c'était
samedi à paris et le chef de file des
insoumis écrit ceci la police tue oui
alors je précise que sur le compte
twitter de jean luc mélenchon il est
indiqué qu'il ne twitte pas en personne
mais lui même a dit qu'il a assumé
totalement ce truies donc je vais vous
le livrer dans sa globalité vous pourrez
le lire à l'écran également la police tu
es le groupe factieux alliance justifie
les tirs et la mort pour refus
d'obtempérer la honte c'est quand voilà
ça c'était donc dimanche soir
à droite les réactions se sont a succédé
à rien que ce matin xavier bertrand
parle de scandale bruno retailleau
condamne des propos intolérables marine
le pen juge elle carrément que cette
façon de mettre en cause l'intégralité
de la police devrait être éliminatoire
en politique et puis à midi la très
discrète première ministre elisabeth
borgne a à son tour condamné les propos
de jean-luc mélenchon c'était sur france
bleu je trouve très choquant la façon
qu'elle jean luc mélenchon de s'en
prendre systématiquement à la police
avec des propos totalement outrancier
moi je rappelle que les policiers ils
exercent une mission difficile au
service des français jean-luc mélenchon
lui il a répété la même idée c'était ce
matin sur france inter oui il ne l'a pas
répété mot pour mot la police tue mais
il a explicité sa pensée écoutez je dis
comme responsable si vous votez pour moi
je changeais la doctrine d'usagé de la
force de police dans notre pays et je
dis que ce n'est pas normal qu'on tue
quelqu'un parce qu'il refuse
d'obtempérer il ya la loi il ya des
punitions il ya des amendes mais pas la
peine de mort alors vous commencez à me
connaître thomas ce qui m'a intéressé
dans l'interview de jean luc mélenchon
ce matin c'est qu'il a carrément lever
le voile sur sa stratégie de
communication il a dit pourquoi il avait
écrit cette phrase ou en tout cas
assumer cette phrase la police tue il a
dit il a écouté mois dans la foulée de
la mort de la jeune femme samedi soir
j'ai écrit un premier tweet et personne
n'a réagi alors je me suis dit je vais
monter d'un ton il l'a dit dans ces
termes là et puis il a assuré que
finalement il avait obtenu le résultat
qu'ils cherchaient ce résultat c'est
d'éveiller les consciences et de marquer
les esprits je pose juste sur cette
table une petite question est ce que il
est de la responsabilité d'un politique
finalement d'assumer et et d'utiliser
les méthodes des populistes est ce qu'il
est la responsabilité d'un homme
politique qui en plus se destine à
matignon d'assumer ses méthodes
populistes et donc le degré d'émotion
qui doit à chaque fois on comprend
maintenant accompagner une prise de
position il me semble tout de même et
nous verrons bien sûr dimanche le
résultat qu'il prend un risque jean luc
mélenchon en optant apparent de la sorte
pourquoi parce que les antilles
mélenchon pourrait se mobiliser
davantage puisque nous sommes dans le
registre de l'émotion prise à l'envers
avec jean daniel lévy tout à l'heure
mais je vous donne la parole à tous les
deux pour pour commencer béatrice giblin
comment vous l'analysez cette sortie
d'un mois sur
la question de la police dans les lieux
où il a eu des suffrages au premier tour
de la présidentielle c'est à dire on va
prendre simplement la banlieue rouge
autour de la région parisienne c'est la
police est un problème réel donc quand
il dit ça il l'espère va c'est une
hypothèse mobiliser son électorat et que
cet électorat qui nous l'a pas vraiment
envie d'aller voter parce que ça les
internes il faut absolument qu'ils se
mobilisent donc si il dit la police tue
ça suffit fait bien avec lui et les
policiers ils vont morfler ouah et c'est
bien ça qu'on doit obtenir avec cet
effet qu'on peut avoir à linverse
effectivement c'est une contre
mobilisation tout plutôt que mouko
mélenchon donc dans quelles proportions
ça va jouer j'avais redit
ici que la carte électorale des
suffrages de mélenchon est une carte qui
est très géographiquement marqué et elle
le restera aux législatives et donc il
va peut-être parfois gagné énormément de
voix sur une circonscription mais ça
fait toujours qu'un député ça n'en fait
pas beaucoup plus et ça sera pour lui un
handicap mais c'est indispensable qu'il
mobilise l'électorat jeune
essentiellement issus de l'immigration
sur lequel il a scoré fortement à son
premier tour des présidentielles
donc c'est de la stratégie à risque mais
toute façon il joue le tout pour le tout
il faut qu'il arrive à au moins 150 ou
180 députés pour que ce soit
effectivement une victoire en dessous
pour être un contre-pouvoir être un
contre-pouvoir 102 et n'étant pas à
l'assemblée lui voilà parce que ceux qui
chassera la nuque le soir le nuancier
sera homogène
après quand il n'avait que ce sera
beaucoup plus difficile de se poser et
maintenir la cohérence sociale sera pas
là parce qu'un chef ça paraît
intéressant pierre jacqmin oui je trouve
que tout ce qui a été dit est très juste
et l'analyse de laëtitia je trouve
l'interrogation sur la question est ce
qu ils font venir à une stratégie
populiste pour se faire entendre de vrai
que vous interrogez nous mêmes
journalistes de dire que pourquoi on
relais pas ou en tout cas pourquoi on ne
on ne raconte pas l'histoire que
mélenchon raconte sur la question de la
police pour qu'on la caricature souvent
comme il est en haut comme étant
quelqu'un d' anti-flics antipolis est ce
qu'il n'est pas il appelle à une police
républicaine donc c'est à nous peut-être
parfois de nous interroger sur les
raisons qui poussent son lit mélenchon a
flirté parfois avec le populisme ce qui
l'a théorisée comme étant un populisme
de gauche il dit juste une seule chose
qui est qui me paraît être absolument
essentiel c'est que il faut changer la
doctrine aujourd'hui de maintien de
l'ordre ce qui expliquait très bien par
des historiens et y compris d'ailleurs
par des docteurs ou des chercheurs au
cnrs comme je pense à fabien jobard qui
l'ex qui l'a très bien expliqué encore
il ya une loi en février 2017 qui a
changé là perception que les policiers
pouvaient avoir de ce qui était la
légitime défense et donc jean luc
mélenchon interroge aujourd'hui le
recours à la légitime défense et la
stratégie qui consiste à ne pas savoir
et où à savoir à quel moment on peut
faire usage
de plein gré consciente de manière
consciente de cette de cette arme et les
armes aujourd'hui les tirs des policiers
ont augmenté de plus de 50% des après
l'adoption de cette loi l'igpn a
elle-même d'ailleurs alerté sur le
danger de ce que provoquer cette loi
donc si on prend sept ça en
considération et qu'on ajoute à ça le
manque de formation des policiers sur
lequel l'emploi sur lesquels jean luc
mélenchon 1,6 particulièrement on met en
danger et les policiers et les ce et la
société donc jean luc mélenchon
peut-être qu'il va trop loin en disant
la police tu lui et ses convives oui
vingt sept quotidiens il dit abus de
pouvoir inacceptable et d'une certaine
façon les juges déjà cessé ses policiers
dans un autre qui ont sans doute dit non
il vise jamais les policiers gens les
plus grands shows regardez bien la
sémantique et utilisez toujours les
donneurs d'ordre mais il a raison ce
sont les donneurs d'ordre et un peu sur
le sur les lignes de crêtes à thomas
c'est pas vrai les donneurs d'ordres
sont très importants voyez comment les
mobilisations
sur la justice et il ya une information
des manifestations dans les
mobilisations sociales aujourd'hui voyez
comme elles sont gérées par la police il
ya eu un changement de doctrine
politique de taux doctrine policières
qui ont rendu les policiers plus sujets
plus susceptibles à faire recours à la
force je rappelle simplement que la
justice travaille information judiciaire
ouverte appel à témoins qui a été lancée
et des policiers qui pour l'instant ces
termes qui a été très clairement
employés n'ont pas été déférés à un juge
d'instruction je voulais vous bouclier
cette séquence jeandel parce
qu'effectivement on voit bien qu'il ya
de la stratégie y a rien en bray
thématiques il ya de la stratégie en
disant je mobilise mon camp mais avec
quels risques de contre mobiliser ce que
vous parliez tout à l'heure et qui est
finalement jean luc mélenchon fait peur
jusqu'à présent l'analyse c'est que ça a
plutôt fonctionné ouais l'analyse en
fait c'est qu'il est arrivé à être au
centre que d'une manière générale quand
vous regardez en fait le genre des
cochons il veut tout politiser et puis
il veut tout conflit tu as lease et mais
là on est clairement avec de manière
assez fracassante effectivement cette
réforme de stratégie sachant que ce
qu'il dit maintenant globalement même ça
renvoie ce qu'il a pu dire juste après
les incidents pour nous dire ça au stade
de france après liverpool enfin dans le
cas de liverpool real où il fallait
réinterroger également les stratégies de
de police donc sont en jeu c'est
vraiment de mobiliser les catégories
populaires
les personnes qui habitent dans les
quartiers populaires et une partie de la
jeunesse c'est là dessus qu'il
bénéficiera ou pas de ce corps qui sont
des scores importants dans le cas du
premier tour pour pouvoir ne serait ce
que d'un point de vue de chiffres être
en tête dimanche prochain et avoir le
plus fort score et seul objectif c'est
de faire en sorte de pouvoir s'adresser
à cela quand vous regardez je crois que
c'est ire ou avant-hier il indique
d'ailleurs que son objectif stratégique
c'est justement de faire en sorte que
cette jeunesse qui était venu à son
secours en tout cas il y avait voté pour
lui à la présidentielle c'est une
jeunesse en plus ce qui s'est vraiment
des gelées comme on dit dans les aciers
du sondage vraiment au cours des deux
trois derniers jours
c'est sous des électeurs qui sont très
politisés sont des électeurs qui
aujourd'hui disent que globalement le
pouvoir leurs yeux et là à l'elysée et
n'est pas forcément au parlement ou a
fortiori à l'international donc plus y
aura un objectif politique majeur plus
cela permettra de déplacer pour aller
voter ce qu'ils avaient servi à
l'élection présidentielle c'était la
peur de marine le pen et le débat qui
étaient installés par marine le pen là
aujourd'hui il cherche à faire en sorte
que en plus de sa présence ce soit un
débat également sur la police la justice
ou la reconnaissance de la jeunesse pour
les inciter à se déplacer pour aller
voter à leur donner un enjeu suffisant
pour se déplacer dimanche prochain tout
dernier mot de conclusion je pense que
macron le laisse aller loin dans cette
mobilisation
parce que comme ça il fait peur et comme
ce sont quand même les personnes de plus
de 55 ans qui vont beaucoup aller voter
aux législatives
elles risquent pas de voka beaucoup
mélenchon et que par peur centre droit
centre gauche et autres risquent de
voter pour lui donc c'est le calcul de
l'elysée bah oui moi je pense que c'est
les deux voilà c'est les deux calculs
dans cette affaire rendez vous dimanche
soir pour voir une première partie delà
de la réponse merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat